wegen des unfalls bildete sich stau
wegen des unfalls bildete sich stau weil
es einen unfall gab hat sich stau
gebildet weil es einen unfall gab hat
sich stau gebildet
es gab einen unfall
deshalb hat sich stau gebildet es gab
einen unfall
deshalb hat sich stau gebildet ich wurde
in meiner kindheit wegen meiner guten
noten gemobbt
ich wurde in meiner kindheit wegen
meiner guten noten gemobbt
ich wurde in meiner kindheit gemobbt
weil ich gute noten hatte ich wurde in
meiner kindheit gemobbt weil ich gute
noten hatte
ich hatte in meiner kindheit gute noten
deshalb wurde ich gemobbt
sie hat die stelle nur
ihres hübschen aussehens bekommen sie
hat die stelle nur wegen ihres hübschen
aussehens bekommen
sie hat die stelle nur bekommen weil sie
gut aussieht
sie sieht gut aus
deshalb hat sie die stelle bekommen sie
sieht gut aus
deshalb hat sie die stelle bekommen
wegen der entlassungen streiken die
angestellten wegen der entlassungen
streiken die angestellten weil viele
angestellte entlassen wurden streiken
sie weil viele angestellte entlassen
wurden streiken sie viele angestellte
wurden entlassen deshalb streiken sie
viele angestellte wurden entlassen
deshalb streiken sie
trotz der probleme bei der anreise haben
uns die ferien gut gefallen
die ferien haben uns gut gefallen obwohl
wir probleme bei der anreise hatten die
ferien haben uns gut gefallen obwohl wir
probleme bei der anreise hatten
wir hatten probleme bei der anreise
trotzdem haben uns die ferien gefallen
trotz der tour
lenzen ist das flugzeug pünktlich
gelandet
trotz der turbulenzen ist das flugzeug
pünktlich gelandet
obwohl es turbulenzen gab es das
flugzeug pünktlich gelandet obwohl es
turbulenzen gab es das flugzeug
pünktlich gelandet
es gab turbulenzen trotzdem ist das
flugzeug pünktlich gelandet
es gab turbulent
trotzdem ist das flugzeug pünktlich
gelandet
ich bin trotz des schönen wetters zu
hause geblieben
obwohl schönes wetter war bin ich zu
obwohl
schönes wetter war bin ich zu hause
geblieben
es war schönes wetter trotzdem bin ich
zu hause geblieben
es war
trotzdem bin ich zu hause geblieben
während des unwetters entstanden viele
schäden an gebäuden und autos
schäden an gebäuden und autos die ärzte
waren während der operation konzentriert
die ärzte waren während der operation
konzentriert bitte gurten sie sich
während des fluges immer an bitte gurten
sie sich während des fluges immer an
während der pausen brauche ich immer
eine zigarette während der pausen
brauche ich immer eine zigarette in
folge einer panne im elektrizitätswerk
fiel der strom in der ganzen stadt aus
infolge einer panne im elektrizitätswerk
er bekam in folge einer kleinen wunde
eine blutvergiftung
infolge des co2 ausstoßes der menschen
erwärmt sich die erde in folge des co2
ausstoßes der menschen erwärmt sich die
erde
angesichts des starken schneefalls wurde
das skirennen abgesagt
angesichts der eindeutigen beweise ist
der angeklagte verurteilt worden
anhand der spuren haben
polizisten den mörder gefunden anhand
der spuren haben die polizisten den
mörder gefunden
seine krankheit konnte anhand der
blutwerte entdeckt werden
mit hilfe eines besseren computers
könnte man bessere ergebnisse erzielen
die diagnose wurde mittels eine
röntgenaufnahme erstellt
röntgenaufnahme erstellt anlässlich
meines 40 geburtstages möchte ich eine
große party machen
anlässlich meines 40 geburtstages möchte
ich eine große party machen
anstatt eines neuen autos habe ich eine
weltreise gemacht anstatt eines neuen
autos habe ich eine weltreise gemacht
ich habe eine weltreise gemacht anstatt
ein neues auto zu kaufen
ich habe angst
moritz max geheiratet
ich habe anstatt moritz max geheiratet
er geht lieber mit seinen freunden ins
kino anstatt die hausaufgaben zu machen
kino
anstatt die hausaufgaben zu machen
anstelle einer lohnerhöhung wurde mir
gekündigt
er hat sich anstelle eines neuwagens
einen gebrauchtwagen gekauft
aufgrund meines wissens gibt es hier
keine giftigen tiere aufgrund meines
wissens gibt es hier keine giftigen
tiere so weit ich weiß gibt es hier
keine giftigen tiere so weit ich weiß
gibt es hier keine giftigen tiere
viele menschen sterben aufgrund des
profits viele menschen sterben aufgrund
des profits
bezüglich deiner frage möchte ich dir
noch antworten bezüglich deiner frage
möchte ich dir noch antworten
ich habe mir noch gedanken bezüglich
unseres letzten gesprächs gemacht
laut einer umfrage sind 40 prozent der
bevölkerung übergewichtig
er ist laut seine sekretärin gerade beim
mittagessen
außerhalb der städte ist die luft besser
die lieferung erfolgt nur innerhalb
deutschlands
oberhalb des waldes befindet sich eine
hütte oberhalb des waldes befindet sich
eine hütte
er hat oberhalb des knies schmerzen
der praktikant wurde trotz seiner
leistung nicht angestellt der praktikant
wurde trotz seiner guten leistung nicht
angestellt der praktikant wurde obwohl
er gut gearbeitet hat nicht angestellt
der praktikant wurde obwohl er gut
gearbeitet hat nicht angestellt der
praktikant hat gut gearbeitet trotzdem
wurde er nicht angestellt der praktikant
hat gut gearbeitet trotzdem wurde er
nicht angestellt möchtest du noch
weitere videos sehen dann abonniere
unseren kanal jeden sonntag ein neues
video
möchtest du noch weitere videos sehen
dann abonniere unseren kanal jeden
sonntag ein neues video